mushrooms are one of my all-time
favorite ingredients I use chestnut
mushrooms with the beef short ribs
because I love their firm texture nutty
taste but as a huge range of other
mushrooms that are great for slow cooked
dishes and when it comes to buying them
there's one expert green grocer who's a
fountain of knowledge borough markets
Fred foster started off on the limply
dead store in Pimlico really had a salad
store with other 20 years of experience
you could actually write his own
mushroom encyclopedia mushrooms as soon
as you pick them the moisture starts
coming out of them so you need to buy
them when they're fresh some products
you smell for flavor
they tend to be fruits mushrooms don't
smell nice until they smell kind of
metallic really so you have to use your
eyes as your guide of what you buy the
mushrooms really really important
wild mushrooms are literally grown wild
in the forests they're just quality
wherever they are
this is morel mushroom a fantastic
products so hard to find in the world
it's almost got an apricot you type of
flavor earthy woody and of course as you
cook it the flavor increases for extra
flavor and texture highly prized morels
are ideal when added to slow cooks
choosing casseroles as are the trumpet
de L'Amour which have a deliciously rich
flavor another wild type to try is the
Jean Trail it's subtle fruity flavor is
delicious and perfect fried with butter
parsley and garlic when you're dealing
with wild mushrooms you need to clean
them it can be quite a slow process it's
with a soft brush don't use water never
use water with mushrooms it deteriorates
the mushroom rapidly oyster mushrooms
are very meaty mushroom just a lovely
silky smooth flavor really nice how do
you tell whether it's fresh those gills
are Brian never cut an oyster mushroom
moist here it look at the whiteness of
that beautiful that would be great if it
was old
although also found wild oyster
mushrooms are more commonly cultivated
along with a similar type the enoki
their delicate taste is grained salads
and soups finally fed saved the best
until last the course the pinnacle is
the truffle they are really really so
often the smell is so intense that smell
it's it's hard to describe because it's
such a unique smell the more expensive
the truffle the more intense the smell
so that's why you use such a small
amount on a dish it's amazing the way
they get these they used to use pigs of
course they don't do that anymore they
use dogsville but because the pictures
to eat them all this magical tasting
funghi is by weight one of the most
expensive foods in the world it's
phenomenal eaten raw shaved over pasta
or risottos or drizzle of truffle oil
turns slow cook stews into something out
of this world people actually scared of
mushrooms are they so it's amazing
really they shouldn't be because take
away the fear and just close your eyes
and taste them they're just amazing
there they are amazing
if you have food that's not perfectly
ripe the tip is to put a banana in a
paper bag then add your unripe fruit put
in a dark place and the banana